keyword is working oh oh oh oh gosh
hello everyone
oh my goodness that was my fault we were
on time until now oh gosh okay so my BA
I forgot to press start on YouTube but
we did start um but now we're actually
live hello everybody
we're playing DC Universe Online on the
switch and right now we are going to
just going through some of the early
cutscenes we're about to get started we
kind of made a little character
resembling Joker but yeah he is didn't
miss much we haven't started playing me
actually
yeah we just customized a character a
little bit which you'll see once we
start and let me make sure the other one
is live
whew okay yeah
maybe we are villains if you want to
live come with me anymore n't we don't
want to alert brainiacs centuries all
right so yeah you guys DC Universe
Online it is on the switch now I think
it came out yesterday can customize a
character we made a female version of
Joker kinda so that was a pretty fun
pretty quick but this is our first
actual chance to walk around and play so
you didn't miss anything you guys if you
do want to check out those early
cutscenes go ahead and download it
because it's a free to play and yeah we
were just talking about how 3d game
free-to-play games are the best
so at least back in the day the way it
works when I was playing was that the
base game that they sold back in like
that stuff's all free so you can make
party crashers like they started
releasing these expansions nice fall day
I said to me be quiet soon and the way
it went
yeah the way it works is you can't buy
them individually and then your account
gets upgraded to like it's you've spent
money version and so they give you more
character slots and some other things
and a bunch of the expansions have
different like character classes like
they did one where it was like you can
make green lanterns or Sinestro Corps
and then they eventually added like all
the lanterns now you could make like a
Red Lantern and the other way that you
can pay for the game is they have a
subscription at least back when I played
they had a subscription where I think it
was like 8 to 10 bucks a month and it
just gave you access to every expansion
and then it gave you like a like a
monthly amount of currency that you
could spend on a store on aesthetic
stuff to customize your look because
this game actually has a super deep like
the gear will change your look that you
can go in and like edit the colors
whenever you want you unlock new outfits
and you can mix and match everything and
like oh I want my legs to always look
like this and you can lock them and
stuff ok it gets pretty deep and pretty
cool and then it becomes like part of
the game you're like oh I want to go do
that mission because I unlock some new
boots
it gets really thanks you might need to
move your Michael o closer it's your
mouth yeah so yeah guys this is free to
play on switch so go and download take
advantage of all these free games and
honestly you know from things I have
seen online and from you know people who
have played it so far this might be the
best version of it yet like the switch
is like the perfect place for a game
like this I guess you could say because
it did come out in 2011 which is a long
time ago I always wonder every time a
game comes out on switch I'm always like
oh god how's it going
this is running pretty decently I'm a
little surprised it might I might
actually go download it because I
haven't played it so long like even just
doing this I'm like oh yeah this games
really fun right it's just all coming
back to you know what I'm I I don't know
if you know the answer to this but do
they have there's no like cross
progression or anything Oh like what you
used to have yeah as far as I know I
don't know anything about that actually
that was a question I was curious about
because it has been out for a really
long time and you know it's pretty much
the same game so I was curious about
that to you but let me look it up I will
say that this has changed a bunch you
like Lex Luthor used to not be here
helping you and I assume if you're a
hero
it's Superman who's helping you because
it was either Superman or Batman but
they used to just be on the radio like
hey there get out of Brainiac ship okay
but now it's done when they added the
ability to skip they must have added
like the characters and stuff in the
actual world and stuff that's kind of
now it's got me curious I'm like what oh
right it's like a homecoming exactly
because when we were making the
character and we were choosing you know
who to base it off of and we obviously
chose Joker I was curious if it made the
story a little different so it's looking
like it yeah that's cool yes heroes and
villains are distinct factions and from
what I remember you can actually pick
servers but I don't know if they change
that so these to be like PvP servers
were like if you're running around
Gotham and you run into another like if
you're playing villain you run into a
hero like you can just fight them
straight up but they would have versions
of servers because to do that or like
you had to flag yourself and stuff
but from what I remember I don't think I
played on a server like that but there
is PvP in the game and depending on if
you're a hero or villain the like main
hub area I would say is different so the
heroes get access to the Justice League
Watchtower which is in space usually you
get to go through this teleporter and
you get to go to space and like Batman
and Wonder Woman and stuff are all there
and one of them is like your your mentor
so you learn like all of your new powers
you get upgrades and stuff from them and
then villains get access to the Legion
of Doom headquarters ok from if anyone
remembers Superfriends back in the day
that thing that would rise out of the
water and was like you get to go you get
to go there but it's this like gigantic
thing which I'm curious to see how that
is changed too because I I haven't seen
it much I mostly play hero characters
this will be a nice yeah you know fresh
take on a game that's been out for a
while so for those of you asking out a
couple of questions you cannot transfer
your accounts yeah exactly so it's
launching on it launched on switch with
a brand new fresh server separate from
all other communities so everyone's
starting from the same level which is
actually kind of nice right because I
feel like sometimes people get scared
too or not really scared but they don't
want to try to catch up like it's
daunting to be like well everyone's
already like a level of million and I'm
starting from zero there's all these
switch people coming in to do a raid and
all of a sudden they're like you know
I'm like I'm gonna I'm on a little bit
of an even floor with people we're all
learning together exactly yeah we got a
new power I just saw see what it I don't
know
does find out oh we got some poison like
farted on him
seems like we just have like a lot of
gadgets and things something else worth
noting is that special care has been
taken to ensure on the go play for this
game and making sure it's as good an
experience as it is docked in your
living room as it is anywhere else all
you need is a little bit of Wi-Fi or
even a mobile hotspot to connect and
play so I actually love games like that
on the switch Tetris 99 is like that I
turn on my hot spot on my phone and I
play off of that and it's always
perfectly fine so I think that's one
thing that this switch is awesome at you
know these games that although it does
require internet it's not like so
intense that you need like really really
good internet exactly yeah and I don't
know unless you're doing that it's not
like a twitch based game like if they
were like oh you got to play apex on
this Wi-Fi hotspot it's like absolutely
not not gonna work yeah this it's a
little bit it's just I'm just beating
stuff up you know here's something
interesting that I just read in this FAQ
is that you do not need a Nintendo
switch online to play this game that is
exactly in dosatron leagues not
expensive but the fact that this is an
an MMO that you don't need to pay like
online subscription for that's pretty
good a lot of I've noticed a lot of
mmo's don't really do that they'll have
optional ones like I think the only two
that really still have paid
subscriptions now that are not optional
is like Warcraft and Final Fantasy I
think every literally everything else
it's like we have the optional one for
the most part you can just play this
game
and like unless you're gonna play this
game super regularly I don't know that
you necessarily need the subscription
you can just buy the packs you want like
oh I want to make a green lantern so
I'll just buy that yeah but if you're
gonna get super invested I think you get
a lot of perks and stuff like you get
extra things that other people don't get
again it's unclear I haven't played this
game in a really long time and you know
what I'm still really surprised with
running as well yeah I was gonna ask you
that next because I saw a few people in
the chat curious about how I ran because
they said they noticed some lag like on
former consoles but it looks pretty
smooth and you have like all these
enemies and a lot of stuff going on well
see once we open the menus that was the
thing that always lagged a lot on like
ps3 like my girlfriend I used to fight
over who had the ps4 one would run so
much faster and then the PSC when you'd
hit the menu button and you'd college it
way like five seconds sometimes like it
just took so long yeah but one big thing
about this game though especially when I
had downloaded it yesterday
it's 24 gigs and the switch itself
doesn't really have that much space so
it's like wow this is a hefty hefty game
so keep that in mind you guys most of my
games physically on switch so like I
don't really have a big SD card so now
I'm like oh that's gonna fill it out
basically like the one that I have in
there yeah so like you can get AB larger
SD card yeah but you know yeah that's
that is one of the things like one of
the downsides of MMOs they're so huge
and a lot of that content is not hosted
on their servers and they probably have
to host a lot of it - they're gonna have
to deal with like the lag and the low
latency and stuff right they're
experiencing on the switch but I mean
it's still free so exactly so free there
bring up your budget a little bit you
can go buy an SD card you just been
getting it XP there we go
I know it's just free XP we're already
like level three alright let's go beat
up Brainiac he's like the like even the
villains are not on brainiacs side in
this game weirdly so what I remember
villains and heroes end up doing the
same raids but I don't know if they can
do it together okay it's done does not
work on him at all I guess we just have
to team up
we might have to download it just to be
Barry Allen you can get pretty close to
being Barry Allen is one of the core
movement our characters Acrobat so they
just run really fast and they just run
up the side of buildings which doesn't
make any sense but whatever but you can
basically make the flash if you want
like and and I'm sure you can unlock
like all of their costume stuff
throughout the game you if you want to
be the flash or Batman you can get
pretty pretty close but it also gives
you a lot of leeway in to like make like
really personalizing it like like
yourself and that's what I kind of like
to do I like to make my own kind of like
weird here I was like when I made my
character I was kind of thinking about
like the crow I was like oh me the crow
boy he had super speed really stupid but
it's it's just I got fun a fun thing
it's wild and wacky and you get to see
everybody's like really unique and cool
designs that they come up with to
oh my god Friz asks what would you
suggest for a new hero what power should
I use power should you use flights
really fun especially when you unlock
the like super version so every movement
you get a super version when you hit
like level 10 or 15 and it's like just
faster so you get this it's like when in
the Superman movies we need watches you
would try to go like fast and then he
would just like kind of like squeeze
really hard he's going really fast you
get to do kind of bad and it you do that
with the speed one two and you go so
fast that it's kind of hard to keep up
but it's really it's it's it's fun oh
yeah and then I thank you for reminding
me that apparently the acrobats can
collide yes you're telling me in this
storyline
everyone has powers pretty much I think
the majority of humans have been given
superpowers in this version of the DC
Universe okay so if if this was real
life which super powers would you pick
for yourself um man flight would be
really cool even though I'm afraid of
heights I would love the ability to fly
I I don't know being able to move stuff
with my mind it is pretty sweet what
about you man I feel like there's so
many super Ahri's but like some sort of
flight it's not flight the definitely
teleportation just like get places
really fast
is the lake teleportation would be
awesome that is a good one what was that
movie with Hayden Christensen we could
look at a picture and like just oh yeah
I oversee I never saw the movie but ever
since I saw the trailer I was like I
want this power like that seems so cool
alright and then I guess we unlocked a
cape oh uh well no capes no okay we put
it on but it's showing up because I
think it's in our style so this is what
I mean when I was they're all locked but
if we wanted we could go to back and be
like this is the cape we unlocked and
like they're kind of like school when it
was on air but no game no game you can
redo your colors like at any time they
have different materials you unlock that
are like metal and different fabrics and
stuff and they get titles but yeah so
like as you go these fill out like
tremendously because you just unlock so
many different things it's fine discard
that's fine so the menu is definitely a
lot more responsive than before and I
think we're in Gotham oh and yeah these
are all just yeah fellow DC you go
players yeah you know what that's pretty
cool actually and like if all your
friends have a switch yeah it's I used
to play with some friends and we used to
do all kinds of goofy stuff because like
you just get to like the there's
multiple open worlds it's like
metropolis so you can just go
Gotham you can just go to other place
like Crime Alley you can go find which
is where Pat man Batman's parents got
shot and there's a bunch of like little
things I used to like just like hanging
out in weird little areas yeah we're in
Gotham it's always nice for some reason
it's always neat yeah and so the heroes
will have like I think they're little
bases are police stations and we go to
like nightclubs we need to go over here
so I can climb up stuff Wow
which looks a little goofy but those but
it's great like uh sometimes she just
goes bald yeah oh yeah is there any
superpower who are you
this is somebody like i weirdly looked
like mine he was a part of the story
he's like wearing that exact code oh
look hey guys so you can glide you're on
a curb add no explanation it's not I
mean have you seen some of those
acrobats and the Olympics very much
doing the same thing exactly
oh yeah so since we're villains we call
being a fight cops oh my gosh
get out of your copper I like a you're
rewarded two for beating up a cop you
spot does not condemn ya harassing
Gotham City police yes this this game is
free so feel free to download it makes
it free but do keep in mind does take up
a lot of space but you also don't need a
Nintendo online subscription to play
either so it's like almost completely
free you use that extra funds to get a
bigger SD card take out rookie cops or
assing Falcone ease men
can do their lore and stuff sort of
sprinkled around the world and if you
get if you find all of the ones in a set
you'll usually unlock like some sort of
style skin for like your weapons or like
a new hat or something so you just get
like all kinds of little neat things
from just exploring the world like
there's all kinds of little things to
find this game actually came out
yesterday for a switch but the game
itself has been out for quite some time
2011 yes it was a premium game back when
it came out right the bar is high now it
feels like 60 bucks and it had the
subscription and I'd played it briefly
and I was like I don't like this and
then when I went free I tried it again
and then I just like I love this is
really fun yeah I think it was pretty
cool like I've been playing some Marvel
Marvel Ultimate Alliance like it kind of
feels like this just a you know beat em
up style but you know definitely
definitely different yeah yeah this is
definitely hello like it has raids and
dungeons me stuff the dungeons might be
like oh stop this bank robbery or
something but like it's if they're all
very superhero themed and things like
that
but the raids get like a little crazy
like the only one that I've ever done
was like you go to Egypt to like fight
black Adams just kind of kind of cool
because he's like one of my favorite
villains and stuff but if you really
like the DC Universe and you like the
comics and stuff it's really cool
because you'll be in the middle of
missions and then all of a sudden it's
like oh man Nightwing just showed up and
he's like fighting with me like it gets
really dorky no that's the best part
yeah that's the best part
what's up eat yeah this is Persia Buddha
also that is Mark Hamill as the Joker he
does a lot of the Joker dialogue in us
oh cool yeah so I'm assuming because we
picked the Joker the Joker is probably
going to be like our mentor as we get to
the Legion of Doom instead we could try
and go to and we got a new power also
hang on how do you use this alright I'm
not sure what that was something did
something we're getting stronger try and
get out of here so I can just too many
like too many cops get on top of this
building really quick look at the map
see where we can go I like all the
windows are just so dirty I know they
they have the dirt flying up a window
cleaner in here stat all right that's
probably good enough let's see you try
and find the map and see if we can find
a
no no it's not what I wanted I just
wanted to zoom out okay I'm just trying
to find like a go Oakland oh yeah the
nightclub okay so that should over there
we go I think we're actually right next
to it
oh we might be on top of it yeah there's
no fall damage you just jump off stuff
what happens when you're a superhero
free your fellow villains yeah exactly
here's wasted in this on ps3 yeah this
no it's not wasted if you had fun yeah
exactly ever consider my time with games
wasted as long as I was having a good
time you weren't having a good time then
yeah maybe sonic SEZ has a plan switch
just like it does it play pretty good I
really like the DC online universe feels
good
someone who explosions into something
know a place pretty good I I think it
was pretty slow on ps3 and it feels
almost exactly like the ps4 version it
feels snappy why didn't you as I say
this why can't I free you yeah now I'm
like stuck oh oh
oh no what happened oh no character
selecting combat whomp-whomp oh wait oh
okay huh okay I'm just gonna leave you
yeah I don't know what's up with you see
if we can try and find the nightclub
because I want to go to the Legion of
Doom and like find the X Bhalla says
this is actually huge an MMO on the go
yeah exactly that's how I was thinking
to myself to you is like that's why is
such a large file but then again you're
gonna like if you're on the go and
you're playing this and it requires
minimal in an egg nation yeah Felix it
is free to play the other thing too is
yeah the MMO on-the-go thing is nice
like I know warframe launched on the
switch and that's also free and that had
like a million people download that
squeezie another game that has taken my
heart what's up crime there we go
oh yeah yes another thing that's like
scattered around the world are these
little challenges so this one is a race
and they and they actually balanced all
of the races around your movement so if
you're a speed one you get a completely
different one than the person who has to
fly cuz like the person who has to fly
their stuff it's all gonna be in the in
the sky and stuff and I'm guessing for
acrobats it's gonna be similar to the
speed one but we're gonna go here and
see if we can find the teleporter to see
the Legion of Doom oh yeah yes let's
finish first
um the switches can connect to the
internet pretty easily via like hotspots
and Wi-Fi and you don't need that much
in it like that strong of internet for
it to connect I've been using like my
phone hotspot to connect for other games
like touch 99 and stuff like that so
that's probably actually one of my
favorite things about switch is that
those games don't require too much
internet to run
so I can throw a game on the girl yeah
what the holiday is coming up you know
how we know he's invincible bugs going
on oh man no no we're stuck again she's
trying to pick the lock
she can't figure it out right in front
of this guy oh boy
definitely some launch oh boy
okay she's back question he were free
yes warframe is on switch like as a
couple months ago okay we're having some
kind of I know I felt like did we leave
the area and like nullify the motion my
character switch here and see let's see
what's going on I like that they throw
in all is this Ardant oh yeah they've
thrown in a lot more as a recently like
this was not a loading screen when I was
playing it ad like this one but that
like and they would just cycle through
those eight over and over again
let's see hopefully this fixes it
Kame hearing punches am I being punished
oh yeah okay it seems so fixed it
you know the classic restarted turn not
turn it back on unplug it plug it back
in all those things are a fantastic
method okay so did it up close to
someone before and I was like I'm not
sure what that was that I just did
alright need to free one more of these
dudes then maybe just maybe we can go to
the Legion of Doom roll them in we'll
pull aggro it's fine
oh yeah good no or hand make sure you're
being secure when you're using your
hotspots make sure you're putting a
password on all that good stuff we
actually did like this you know online
like training thing here at office and I
learned way more stuff than I thought
I kind of was more curious to see like
what I learned I didn't already know but
it was pretty good but I got to be safe
out there I was like gonna put something
in the skill tree yeah but the cops are
here I know retrieve Joker explosives
okay yeah I know crime I need to get
some Ricola or something I lost my voice
i Evo it was too high couldn't help it
it's always a sign of good event
yeah if I lose I lost my voice every III
you know you've had fun when you when
you screamed too much exactly okay so
those are these are two abilities we can
unlock this interrupts and deflects
strong range to sustained charge up
attacks this one we go backwards dive
with pistols fire yeah that one's like
movie magic action okay so it should be
for those of you asking about how it
runs I mean we've been playing a little
bit now and some of the instances
there's like a ton of enemies and you
know we're hacking and slashing it's
been holding up pretty well yeah so not
bad not bad
unlocked all those but now I'm trying to
find out how
Oh loadouts here we go so like you
instead of in a lot of other MMOs it's
like like wow you have just icons cuz
you can use any ability you want this
game it's more like you create a loadout
and then you sort of are like well I'm
using these abilities let's see what
fear gasps okay I thought we had
unlocked these oh I see it's just a
combo thing so tap X and then hold X
economy so if we go there we go all
right cool yeah now we can dive all
right now maybe
okay that's fine
it's one of those lore things we'll skip
it but if you care about like DC
Universe lore and stuff there's like
little sites and things to go back
what's heroes name and backstory we
didn't really come up with a backstory
we shame I know that she's based on the
Joker yeah so this is Joker's nice
long-lost knees she does have a Harley
look going on to a little bit yeah tails
rig cop cars okay
again don't recommend doing this in real
life yeah we are playing villains let's
see look at this guy there's all kinds
of people come up with really cool
Coligny characters in this game yeah is
this game playing better I think so like
it didn't work well on ps3 I don't I
don't think and I don't think it ever
really gotten true ps4 it worked really
really well but this is controlling
really well I'm actually impressed I was
a little scared that it wasn't going to
work super well this is my experience on
the ps3 but it's running really really
well now I think we know download this
when I go home yeah and you were
mentioning like one big thing was using
the menus and the menus used to you know
take a really long time back on the ps3
versions boding was that your move yeah
it just a little wait yeah that's okay
we got it figured out all right we got
you two more car bombs oh my god get
away from me here we go
this guy's doing the same mission as you
know know so many villains I know not
enough not enough good guys here for all
these villain who take out yeah I do
like that no matter what faction you
play you in have it sort of the same
space as everyone else like you know the
heroes and villains are in the same
places and so you will run into them and
depending on whether or not you care
about PvP you will you do earn stuff for
PvP so if you find heroes out in the
world and you're playing a villain and
you want to oh
1v1 me bro these are like crafting
materials that you find and my god when
I was playing we were obsessed with just
we would spend whole nights just sitting
on the couch coming around like
metropolis like going oh I found one
because they you need it later on to
build to build new gear it suddenly
becomes very important it during the
when you're first start playing you're
like oh I don't care about these and
then you hit a certain point you're like
oh boy I need to I need to find all of
them now do we have to buy a ridiculous
amount of DLC you don't have to buy any
of the DLC the DLC is mostly like
optional content like a lot of it is
just different character classes and
stuff although some of them are story
content like a lot of the things they've
been releasing now they haven't really
been adding classes to it they've been
basically adding like I added Atlantis
recently mmm sounds like a big Aquaman
that's great an expansion and some other
things but like you can pay for it over
time you know if you're gonna play this
game a lot or you can do the
subscription model which just gives you
access to all of it and then just like
re-up your subscription when you're like
I'm gonna go play this for like a couple
weeks it's really up to you I
I don't recommend just going in and like
buying everything in a way cuz you might
not even play it like stick with it yeah
play all of the free stuff first you
know and then once you have gotten
through that which will take quite a
while then be like okay I kind of want
to play a you know a Green Lantern or I
kind of want to do some of this other
stuff and like do these these story
missions of these other raids then just
go like one by one and buy them or just
you know get your subscription so chat I
want to know who's your favorite DC
character tell you mine
yes you you as well my favorite
characters Shazam actually Oh
free free movie Zachary that my favorite
character has always been Shazam well we
can go back inside okay good and the
reason is is because I always kind of
liked the idea that it's just like a kid
in like a man's body and it's sort of
just this like you know when you're a
kid you sort of feel powerless and so
like the power fantasy of being a
superhero is super like cool and also I
just really love mythology and there's a
lot of that in Shazam and stuff and so I
just love always would like gravitated
toward the character and I was so happy
when that movie was actually good I was
incredibly excited my favorites hmm I
guess I don't really have to think about
it because I'm also limited and the
characters actually Noah frame but I
guess I would probably go with
I don't know I don't know maybe I take
it you're more of a marvel I am more of
a marvel phrasing that's I'm trying to
think about like what I really good
Maura Maura good answer I mean I could
be I could like take the cop out and say
Wonder Woman you're allowed to like
whoever you want to like I don't like I
feel like when it comes to some of the
like DC characters there are things I
like about them and then things I don't
like so when I'm coming when someone's
like pick a favorite I'm like hmm who do
I just like everything about it's
definitely a different flavor because DC
is really weird as someone who is really
into the DC universe and what it tends
to like it a lot more than Marvel it is
more like the characters are more like
Greek gods they're not really like
normal people
whereas in Marvel it's just like someone
you know it's just like Oh someone got
superpowers but they're still in high
school and they have a big problem and I
like that too but I've always really
gravitated towards the kind of like the
myth of it all I like I like that you
know Superman is like larger than life
but still sort of grounded in a way mm
and just everything feels like very
cosmic and weird in a way that like
Marvel also does but I feel like DC just
sorta does in its own really interesting
way but I also like that they have this
multiverse that the Marvel comics don't
really touch on much like in every
single DC Universe is always is like
super weird and incredibly different
from the other ones and it's nice
because then they get to make these
really interesting comics that don't
affect like the main continuity because
they can just be like oh it's earth
eight don't worry about it you know I'm
like so then people get to like remix
the characters and people don't really
get angry about it cuz it's not the
prime
like universe it's like all Superman's a
communist like let's have fun doing this
and stuff so and I know Marvel has like
what if and they haven't they have to
mine all haven't done that in a while
but they have they do have the TV show
coming now like I would say Batman but
honestly I just really like all the
Arkham games they're really good I'm
like is he my favorite though you know
yeah as a kid I probably would have said
that but as I got older like I still
really like Batman but I I tend to
gravitate more like fun colorful things
and so I write how about squirrel okay
squirrel girl
oh she's marvel Oh ding body and see I
can't even like reach for anybody who is
this Laura maybe it wasn't us girl or
was it like a hot girl I was trying
remember who was in injustice yeah I was
like it was some czar animal followed by
girls like Hawk Eye is my woman hot girl
they say they're like Egyptian royalty
that's curse to be reincarnated fall in
love and then the moment that they fall
in love they get murdered that's a real
curse
yes so there have been many times in the
DC continuity where they have you know
expressed their love for each other is
only to be murdered like right after so
it's very sad which is why I'm that is
really sad if you ever watched did you
ever watch the Justice League cartoon uh
no that was on Cartoon Network so they
did an interesting thing where like they
kept that piece of lore except hot girl
ended up falling in love with Green
Lantern and it became this weird like
love triangle between
like because like they in a past life
you know they were together but now like
all of a sudden it's like that's not the
thing and so there's this whole like
jealousy thing oh man that's even worse
it's super good like that cartoon is
incredibly good you just wanna like
destroy everyone's hopes of love or way
yeah there's been a lot of a lot of
interesting things like that's one of
the things I love about comic books in
general is like they reinvent themselves
like every so often and like so you get
all these really different
interpretations of these characters that
everyone loves which I find really
interesting I'm not even sure what we're
doing here I'm just punching stuff okay
well we're recovering all over here all
the right pieces yeah we got body you
know they all got beat up right next to
each other so we don't have to travel
too far exactly
what's up goob yes I am back in Mugen
there hasn't been any news on cross
plates which as of right now everything
is brand new and fresh fresh start for
everyone and ya know never watched
Justice League Unlimited I think when I
was growing up and watching at cartoons
it was like Rocko's Modern Life I'm like
yeah like you know those cartoons it was
like comic II like honestly I didn't
even see any of the really good like
Marvel cartoons back then either like I
only saw them now like in current times
going back to watch them but I had never
seen those like as they were coming out
but they were also good so I definitely
have no doubt Justice Justice League
Unlimited was probably really good also
oh okay so this must be some event
that's going on right now I definitely
left my boys at Evo goo but that is
correct
hopefully they'll uh send it back to me
sometime this week oh we're going to a
warehouse to protect some Joker shipment
so let's go do that yes maybe the Joker
actually show up I know right
instead it is yelling at us on the x-men
was the best hero cartoon I didn't watch
a lot of x-men cuz it was on Fox I think
I mostly why it was a Cartoon Network
kid there anything you know one thing I
did always appreciate from all of like
the comic cartoons that they're in shows
are always godlike the music is always
on point the x-men animated theme was
still is just amazing trying to think of
the other one that always sticks mine is
the Batman animated series one the one
is just like probably one of the most
iconic Supergirl things ever Oh Catwoman
ring a fight Catwoman or sneaking up on
maybe she's a villain I don't remember
okay I guess I guess she's a friend it's
hard to it's hard to you know tell with
Catwoman cuz she flips on a dime so
often
okay yeah that's part of what I mean is
like you'll just be doing missions and
all of a sudden these like characters
you really level just like you know and
sometimes you're like fighting him or
sometimes they're helping you like what
was the name of that one it was like a
movie but basically Batman was like
shooting people and I was like whoa I
was like that's not a thing it was like
a it was animated I think yeah it was
like more like it was Thomas Wayne I
think and not Bruce Wayne because Thomas
Wayne famously uses guns and it's like
this other universe version of Batman
yeah it was definitely another universe
and another universe and I don't I
forgot what I was like something paradox
or something like that I think so
that word is standing out to me but I
remember someone showed that to me and I
was like man this verse was written from
Batman though he is serious things I
love about the DC universes they just do
all these they do these really well
there you go flash plain yeah
that's right yeah it's one of the ones I
haven't seen aren't so famous
oh nope get that out of here oh maybe I
should punch it okay I thought I had to
like crack into it or something but I
guess I just punched safes open
all right and they only send one guy oh
nice my force field then noise noise
yeah flashpoint paradox I remember
someone showed that to me after um me
and a group of friends were having like
this huge debate like they always loved
to do about all of the different heroes
and then randomly that one came up and
like half the group had seen it and half
the group hadn't seen it so we were like
trying to explain to them that or they
were trying to explain to us that it was
like not the actual reality because our
other friend was trying to be like nah
this version is the best version they're
like does that even count although in
the Golden Age Batman did use guns for a
while in the 30s and he was just like
murdering people left or right whatever
and then and then like you know the mob
started gaining all this stuff in like
the 40s like they were becoming more of
a like thing in the news and there were
all these parents that were like you
know gun control became a big thing and
so then all of a sudden the editors of
DC were like maybe you shouldn't use
guns anymore maybe should probably be
like more a little bit more of a
positive role model and stuff so then
they took the guns out like in an
editor's note and this old like Batman
16 or something and he hasn't done it
since other than like the occasional
little moments he's changed his ways ya
know all he did okay Jesse's right
because I've seen I've seen that panel
and he did hang a do Huntress he did
hang a dude from a helicopter it's
that's that's legit
dang yeah
you should see Justice League war it's
much better than flash plain hey I'm
always open and checking out new stuff
to the eye some are better than other
others obviously but they're very
enjoyable what was your opinion on the
Justice League movie or a live-action
that universe but I have hope that they
can turn it around I think I think the
Joker movie looks really good even
though it's not part of it oh oh yeah I
flubbed the intro of this chain today so
we're joined by Josh today he's our EDC
extraordinary he played this game you
know before I was on switch yeah ps3 ps4
so checking it Allen now freshly on
switch someone earlier was like isn't
this game like a decade of almost
although we came on 2011 a few years
short okay we just earned some new legs
yeah you see here's something that I
think maybe hinders certain brands right
and I'm a good example so I I hadn't
seen much of Justice leaguer like DC
stuff really at all and then you know
the movie start coming out
Justice League came out I saw Justice
League and I was like this is horrible I
hated everything about it and that was
just judged off of the bare minimum of
what I knew about the DC Universe right
like the flash got shot and in my mind I
was like isn't he supposed to be like
super fast and like yeah not every you
know is that is that something that
happens to the flash like he he can't
dodge a bullet I don't know the and like
I said this is coming from this is
coming from someone with minimal
knowledge about the DC Universe so I was
just like I'm pretty sure the flash is
not suppose
exactly
Kaspar just said scarecrow for some
reason but I just have to go off on the
fact that scarecrows like one of my
favorite in our community jizz with
Jericho those are really good I'm sure
that the designers love to those stages
too because they got to get super wacky
with with it yeah yeah I I loved
scarecrow I've always liked like
Halloween kind of stuff and he's very
like oh yeah someone in chat was
mentioned what do you think about Robert
Pattinson playing Batman is that still a
thing I heard that set I think oh yeah I
heard so I thought someone backed out he
backed out of it you know everyone gives
Robert pets in a hard time because he
was in Twilight and let me tell ya
not only have I read every Twilight book
I watched the first movie and it's not a
good movie and he's not good in it he's
actually a really good actor like he's
been in other movies where he's very
good actors so like if he wants to be
Batman I'm okay with that I'm okay with
seeing you know that version of Batman
and if it's and if people don't like it
it's fine there'll be other Batman's
they've been so many so far there's
gonna be more you know it's not I don't
think it's that big a deal but I I'm I'm
interested to see like if if that does
happen his take on it because I actually
do you think he's a good actor despite
being in Twilight I mean you know I was
a teenage girl once and I for a while
was super into Twilight and then you
know I got older and I was like man this
is such a negative like example for all
of like our young girls out there like
you don't need no man even if he's a
fine vampire or
or crazy wolf boy you know but I don't
know yeah I read them all because one of
my friends was reading it and she made
me read it and at first I was like yeah
this is good and then by the time I got
to the fourth one I was like I'm done I
got pretty wild it did I got pretty like
I got kind of insane yeah I mean when
you start having vampire babies that's
how you know yeah this story is getting
wild weird yeah Robert Pattinson I think
he I think he could be good I first was
like oh man I don't know about this
Joker movie you know and then I saw the
trailer and I was like you know what
this looks real good like it looks
really weird and I'm all about weird so
I I'm like just get weird with it like
who cares just do it it's gonna be cool
crying makes a good point
he says DC has some cool characters and
stories never used any of them in the
movies and yeah I agree like because
both like DC and Marvel they have like
so many characters but we really only
see a few of them out in the actual
movies and stuff like that yeah I know
you know a character that I really like
that I don't think ever really gets any
time like in movies and stuff it might
be different with the TV shows is like
the question like is this like faceless
detective was a woman I can't remember
her name like after there was an event
called like the 52 where he died and
then she took like his weird mold face
and like put on and she became the
question and stuff and it was over an a
Montoya that was her name
name and that was cool stuff I they
never play with that like that would be
really cool because because the face can
be molded he could be like so many
different actors like at the same time
it'd be kind of neat and the way are
like special effects and CGI has been
advancing yeah deep fakes just deep fake
the movie
all right they want to try one of these
races Team Jacob right Team Edward Josh
I think I was Jacob back I don't quite
remember but yeah yeah I was Team Jacob
do not gonna lie cuz I was salty like
ever just left
oh here we go it's so it's so weird
because it's Ben I was in high school
when I read those so that would have
been more than more than a decade ago I
graduated in 2008 and I think I read
them in like 2007 so or around 2008
around then so it was it was it's a lot
it's a long time it's like a whole
lifetime ago basically for me I have no
idea for doing well oh I think we're
doing okay you got this losing our
acrobatic skills yeah some of them get
pretty hard parkour this Swamp Thing TV
shows must be good
according to GameSpot calm it's very
good I haven't watched it there we go
gold medal oh we could have gotten
platinum though two seconds 2.7 seconds
yeah let's see oh you know what though
another game that actually got me a
little bit more familiar with DC
characters was injustice the fighting
game yeah yeah I played that a bit and
it's cool because I like that they play
with all of the multiverse stuff and
they let you just do all kinds of wacky
just things and that game like weird
with costomer it's like it's Green
Lantern buddies blue you're like okay
just let's just have fun you know I like
that kind of stuff I missed what we were
hurry to Cape carmine okay hey oh my god
it's really far oh so we're in the
Botanical Garden so there's
around Poison Ivy's uh poison ivy I
forgot about her I actually liked her a
lot
yeah I remember there is if you play
heroes there is a boss fight where you
go into like you go into someplace on
the edge of Gotham and it's all
overgrown with plants and stuff and it's
like it's basically a dungeon you fight
all these plant monsters and then you
fight poison ivy at the very end it was
really cool like the early missions
you're kind of like okay and then when
you get to a certain point you start
like actually interacting with the
Justice League and stuff that gets me
wasn't it uma Thurman who played poison
ivy she's great
Batman and Robin yes
that was the fourth one channel channel
correctly yeah machinery of like course
I dodge all the bullets just trying to
get us there as fast as possible it's
it's it's weird cuz I never play the
Acrobat I always liked playing speed or
flight we're halfway there
yeah the what I like about this game too
is like just the city maps are whoa
freaking out that's something only a
villain could do Park yeah breakdance on
a ceiling the open world maps are huge
like pretty much see if we can go like
up really high but like you can go
anywhere close map someone messages game
spot forever
yeah you found hey hey Chris don't hate
that move was great that movie was great
for its time all right
yeah was that the same one Lou with
Arnold Spurgeon here is that it yeah
that was great times like I used to see
you I need to go watch that movie now
yeah and then Robin and his wax lips
oh haha oh my god I forgot all of it
yeah he takes that he has he put wax on
his lips so you wouldn't get poisoned or
whatever that's so men so yeah yeah
there was a good my favorite youtuber is
Patrick Williams he does like a lot of
superhero and movie analysis and stuff
and he did a video about like why we
don't appreciate those I was like man I
kind of wait I go watch them they seem
campy and fun it's like let's let's try
it out I I liked it as a kid that movie
came out as a kid never my dad like I
just remember feeling so bad for Arnold
Schwarzenegger and his whole story I was
like oh before I go yeah Mr Freeze it
has a pretty tragic backstory suddenly
can't remember but I it's something
about his wife that's all I remember
yeah yeah some unfortunate circumstance
social says Persia's because of that
movie we didn't see a Batman movie until
2000 me so in the end it was worth but
that's one of the things that I kind of
liked about Batman is there like so many
different incarnations owns like there's
the goofy Adam West's Batman which
people seem to like have kind of come
around on like I know that hardcore
Batman fans back in the 60s hated it and
there was like a large contingent of
people that didn't like it but kids of
that era really liked it and now we're
looking back on that you know now that
Adam West is dead and we're kind of like
oh yeah this was fun and dumb but it was
like enjoyable and now like goofy Batman
has sort of become like a little more
accepted alongside dark menacing you
know brooding Batman and I like that you
can have all these different
interpretations of a character that's so
like beloved like these characters have
been around almost a hundred years which
is insane to think about like we are
let's see 11 years possibly probably
from like almost like a hundred year
anniversary I was at the comic-con Rose
like the 80th anniversary Superman or
whatever and it was was nuts and it's
like trying to think about that I'm like
when I was born this was like still 60
years older so you know what I mean and
now it's like they've been with us for
so long his wife is dying of an
incurable disease that's right and then
it like blew up or something guys I
can't remember if it was take out
strongmen delay oh you you're the guy
you know carrying the box we're gonna
fight these boxes dierence okay my box
let's see no just looking around for
boxes okay I'm kind of call shenanigans
on Batman ninja I don't I didn't like
that movie unfortunately if you liked it
man more power to you I'm glad somebody
laughs I'm glad somebody liked it that
was not a big fan of it later than their
strong me anything where is max get back
here well I destroyed the box but now he
can't take it so we got in yet another
power oh there he is
let's try this Oh nein it's like it's
gonna be a Gunners yeah
dang hit you at her max all right let's
just try to retreat to the tall
buildings as they can't get you up there
here we go
all right finished that search for veins
venom distribution house okay so Dirk
Ola that is like the coca-cola of sodor
Batman does have the best villains
Batman has a large swath of villains
yeah lot of people here now that we've
actually you know what now that we're
playing a villain and we've talked about
our favorite heroes who's your favorite
not even just deceive a who's your
favorite comic book villain like in
general my favorite villain Magneto
Magneto that's a good pick you know wait
am I going the wrong way I think I'm
going along just punch down
oh I see over here steal venom from
razors okay we'll figure it out just can
be some people of yeah yeah how happens
along the way yeah I think of my I mean
I do we talked about scarecrow I love
scarecrow I don't know that I have a
favorite Marvel villain but I like the
really goofy things like Galactus I it I
I find the idea of just a planet eating
person just sort of silly and weird and
I kind of like when comic books they're
silly and weird and there's even more
like hilarious that like ghostwriter is
like his demon because he does Arab the
guilt chain around him guilt I've never
read a ghostwriter thing and then he
just like you know feels guilty for all
those planets he can zoom I was a shadow
fan when I was a kid not cool I played a
lot of Sonic Adventure 2 it's like I
feel like whenever I think of magneto I
always have to remind myself oh I guess
he's technically a villain yes but he's
like a sympathetic villain you know like
I get it which I think are usually the
best villains that are just evil cuz
they want to be evil or not as
interesting okay pretty strong actually
in DC probably Superman Superman is a
good choice I know like there are a lot
of people that don't necessarily like
Superman darksied is another great
choice Chris I love you're burnin Cap'n
I'm gonna run away from these guys I
think a lot of people don't like
Superman but they haven't read the right
Superman books yet that's the way I you
know that's usually how I feel about
most comic related things
like there are a lot of different comics
and different versions and different you
know episodes are like you know all of
the above right
I had a Superman comic in my head that I
was gonna recommend and now I can't
remember what it was but I have another
my favorite probably DC comic ever made
is Superman red Sun have you heard of
this no so come with me on a journey
check you're gonna die
Superman red Sun oh my god drink some
soda some soda go we'll hang out a sec
Superman red Sun isn't it's called an
Elseworlds tail which is like just an
alternate earth so they just go kind of
nuts with it it's what if Superman
landed 12 hours later than he did which
means that he didn't land in the United
States he landed in Soviet Russia
whoa and so he's basically like a
communist superhero and Lex Luthor still
born in America so it has this whole
like Cold War thing going on
it is incredibly good and it's it's
pretty short I love that yeah it's it's
a it's one of my favorites it's
incredibly good I love that because it's
like such a simple concept as he just
landed a little bit later that's it and
then it changes everything so
drastically that's pretty cool they even
mentioned like like oh well if he had
landed like sooner he would you know he
would have been ours and then he
wouldn't have been a problem instead
they do all kinds of interesting stuff
and a lot of other DC characters you
might not expect actually show up in it
too which is really surprising yeah it's
a good book you can probably get it
pretty pretty cheap now it's a little
it's older it's modern but it's like I
don't know 10 years old ish maybe but
very good highly recommend chat yeah I'm
curious I definitely want to check it
out yeah all right I need to drink some
soda in the Middle's battle real quick
all right come on
okay we earned this oh we got a couple
things hang on well we get okay we have
to pick up our now let's see we are
level 10 so we can pick literally any of
these names elect incoming attacks and
that's boring
clown box that actually sounds cool wrap
yourself in a giant clown box while
you're inside the box emits deadly nerve
yeah I like that yeah
alright let's vary on brand for Jawa
Joker here we got gear to you that I
have not been oh yeah weak I guess
strong style like that yeah so some
items are actual items and then other
items are styles that you unlock so if
we look at some of these I'm sure we've
unlocked some somewhere they're not
showing up but yeah I do like that in
this game you can just change like your
appearance and stuff just like whenever
you want okay I like that I wish more
games did that but now I'm trying to
find yeah I'm definitely a huge sucker
for your character customization oh hey
okay we got it slotted in so it's yes
it's awesome
that's pretty okay alright we're gonna
use like 50 dudes around us I think it
gotta go this way
here we go yeah that's cool
stocks are just minding their own
business their venom eyes those guys
it's the muscle you'd worry about yeah
Brian says I've been looking for a
switch mm oh so I'm thinking about
trying it yeah I mean why not it's free
yeah you have nothing to lose exactly
maybe sometime play it like I like that
Nintendo's getting a lot more open to
like having free to play mm-hmm and then
those and stuff on here
it's like warframe is another really
good choice it's an amazing game that I
think more people should play and this
one too I think it's a really good
really fun game it's fun too and you
have like friends to play with I don't
know what we're doing with this okay
converse says this is the superhero game
of my childhood ish was a good game for
they're a very underrated it is
underrated I agree and now we're hanging
out with Killer Croc fighting venom
supplier Diego fun thing is if you play
heroes in your starting city oh is
Gotham we're gonna box them yeah Wow
good okay we're not done if you play
heroes and you start in Gotham and you
do this mission it's it's completely
different that you actually fight Killer
Croc as the boss at the end and you team
up with Nightwing to like bust the the
venom ring and it's pretty it's pretty
neat how they repurpose like their
content stuff let's see we replay value
yeah
[Music]
traitor
oh okay I probably just read the breeds
a thing that says what I'm supposed to
do leave distributions empty sorry got
it got it will do fine I know when I'm
not once welcome here I'm hoping that
after that can actually go see the
Legion of Doom because I want to see it
before we got a wrap-up here yeah so got
about 12 minutes yeah oops let's see we
go to any and I'm like looking through
the website for this game to everybody
does like so cool yeah this I'm gonna
guess that someone's character I have no
idea yeah sorry guys aren't looking um
but to be fair there are a ton of like
there are so many characters just in
like even in DC and Marvel and stuff
that like even sometimes under your
reading modern comics all of a sudden
someone pulls up some character from
like 1946 that had like 10 issues of
something and they're just there and
you're like who you have to go to
Wikipedia you're like who is this person
it's like I had to do that with like
Adam Strange once when I was reading
like a comic all of a sudden they're
like oh it's Adam strange I'm like Who
am I
oh it's this DC character from like 1952
that was like popular for a hot minute
and he hasn't had a comic book in like
decades they just hear what is that okay
just fire
this character looks like Raven I think
that is Raven oh there's a mission that
you do in the base they are teen titans
easy Robin you know actually I think I
did know that subconsciously because
Starfire is an injustice yeah yeah
that's okay that's okay there's a
mission Hey connecting dots guys that I
remember where you break into the you
break into some Museum it might be like
the metropolis Museum and it's like
Raven fighting her father and then you
have to like go inside Ravens mind and
like fight like personalities of her
it's really cool anyway I like always
like they're in Teen Titans because she
is like so email all the time and I was
like oh it's me and it's great it's
definitely one of my favorites well now
that I know this I can say I think
Ravens my favorite what's your opinion
on Teen Titans go have you ever watched
it I have yeah you know it's hard to
like that when you watch like the
original teens I straight but I watched
in the theaters with my friends Teen
Titans go to the movies and that was
actually really good and I'd be in they
showed the clip they showed like a it
was like after credit scene or so and it
was pretty cool they showed like the
original version they were like hello is
this thing on and I'm like ding they're
so cool I I'd never watched it and then
I went to yo dragon listen what up and
yeah even she's awesome I felt like I
related to her oh yeah
we're holy holy villains I think they
cuz when you when you fly you just fly
over the water and then when you can run
so fast
obviously you run on top of the water
and I think they were just like well we
don't want to make the Acrobat people go
around so I'll just have them walk on
the water it's whatever
he's not there like whatever it's comic
books like hand-wave it's fine
yeah didn't you know acrobats can walk
on water yeah that's why they have at
the Olympics I don't know what that is
but I'm gonna stay away from it
I'm not going anywhere near that I'm
just trying to go see they will read run
of doom see if we can find our Father or
our uncle Joker
where are you eh whoa yeah some things
have definitely changed because I don't
remember that the pillars of Hades added
that around like some Wonder Woman thing
that was going on or something almost
there it says DC Jesus they see Jesus
yeah that's uh God actually does exist
in the DC Universe sort of the inspector
is his agent I don't think we ever like
see God it's just like he's just like
armored professional of God all right
and I well Marvel yeah there's
Christianity and Marvel this is in our
world and there's summon some of some
heroes are our Christians and like a
whole there's a whole arc about that at
some point let's see is this cross way
with other platforms no it is not
unfortunately it's its own being maybe
in the future though they'll add it I
just want everything to be cross play
forever yeah right
no more bad days oh wait it's letting us
go to other places do the Chinese am
trying to figure out how to go we can go
to if we can't go to the Legion of Doom
we can at least not God in the check
he's here he's there does talking you
see why don't we let's go to Metropolis
since I can't figure out how to get to
believe him do him anymore
yeah no way is this outside yes it is
scarecrow oh boy
oh snap oh he looks cool in that one do
ya they kind of did like a like a half
way between the Arkham One and the
animated series one what if he looked
like that scarecrow but he was more
scary scary your crows scarier crow here
we go
we look so out of place I know this is
metropolis and it's a whole other world
map with stuff to collect the Sun is out
yeah and the Sun is out I think I think
metropolis has a day/night cycle I'm
pretty sure
okay I'm not not totally sure but I know
that Gotham is usually always at night
so I got the Superman memorial statue
cuz he died that one time whoa whoa I
got an achievement we could have I saw
Crime Alley on the map we could have
gone there but I think it's literally
just like an alley and you're like okay
so I guess is where Batman parents died
Azrael I feel like they're obligated to
put that alley in there yeah I mean you
know they got you got it and I gotta let
you know where it is to thing go look at
it there's also so many stories where
like Batman's gone back to it and it's
just kind of like one of those iconic
things I'm like let's see if we can find
the Daily Planet also like a your
missions like get out of this area
you don't belong here go back to Gotham
yeah like hey all weekends because there
are it even um so yeah there's all these
things like area area 51 and oh oh storm
that I guess makes a long time it's
basically just this large group event
thing where there's little isn't it 30
people in there yeah this you were doing
it back in 2011 exactly you're outta
there Johnny yeah they were there they
were there eight years before the raid
that is amazing yes is the area 51 thing
here
you know I guess we could just do let's
look at the map but it's on their points
of entry as we go around and find the
8th precinct can't go there okay I don't
I don't know where it is but whatever
we'll just we'll just climb things and
see if we see it but a DC universe which
match P essence which if you're asking
if it does cross play it doesn't
hopefully in the future it'll have cross
play because that would be nice I have a
high level character on ps4 and I think
I want to play more of this but I don't
want to abandon my character at the same
yeah we'll see
it's like cross play to gaming is like
what world peace is to it's like I know
if only we could just get everybody on
board did you okay with this Oh
whenever the prompts come up makes you
fall thankfully there's no fall damage
so we'll be okay but even the buildings
in Metropolis are dirty yeah they never
get washed I know like that so these
don't look like windows they look like
steel come on just trying to see
everything so those Brainiac ships going
on over there there's another race music
from somewhere there's the Brit I think
that's the bridge to Gotham I don't know
if you can take that though oh that
would be cool yeah because a Gotham is
across the water from metropolis but New
York also still exists like there's just
yeah so like all the cities you know
about exists like San Francisco is still
a thing but there's like eight other
cities that exist there's like Coast
City Emerald City metropolis Gotham
those the only ones I remember Star City
sure there's more but I always thought
Gotham was like based on the
I think they're all sort of because DC
and Marvel were in New York I think so
much of what New York is is was baked
into them but no I think New York is
actually still a city in the DC Universe
but they they just don't talk about it
that much it's very it's this very weird
thing that separates I mean that could
also just be my biasness in New York
like every time I think big city I'm
just like New York I've lived here my
whole life so I wish I think of San
Francisco's Gotham's in New Jersey do
you remember that song since you're a
fan of Batman and Robin do you remember
the r.kelly
Gotham City song know where he clearly
had never like read a Batman comic ever
it's about how Gotham is just like the
dopest place to live it's it's so
awesome there's no crime here I it's
it's not a it's not a good song but I
recommend going and looking it up cuz
it'll make you laugh I thought Gotham
was Chicago for some reason it has a lot
of those vibes I think a lot of those
vibes come from like Chicago just was
always like a hotbed for like noir
stories and Batman has a lot of noir and
like mob stuff to it and I think that
that parallel probably gets drawn more
than more than people realize yeah Kevin
also in the Chad thing yeah Gotham is
Chicago yeah pretty high up and honestly
still some free to use either like some
games when you go to like high points
like that oh yeah stuff down at the
bottom gets like muted up yeah because
this games so old they've been able to
just like they're like oh if we just
keep the same aesthetic and stuff slowly
and but surely okay you know it'll it'll
just like the draw distance I'll get
nuts it's like you can see bullets and
stuff flying down there all that dang
they film Dark Knight it they did film
Dark Knight in Chicago I think a lot of
city films get filmed there and then in
- wrong - I think it depends and like
sometimes they even do them in different
like well do different scenes and other
cities and stuff yeah oh there's a quest
down here we can do that let's just fall
why not alright this will be the closing
quest what a minion of greed you got it
you got it minion of greed
you know what those medicines they're
worth top dollar top dollar
let's see if we can converted citizen
tanky here we go yeah this is the this
stuff here steal medical supplies let's
do it
here we go Bryan says I always assume
New York but don't New York is also
referred to in my as Gotham I feel like
I've heard Hell's Kitchen more like that
be like the even though that's like one
little specific area I always hear that
term wouldn't be really talking about
just New York New York in general yeah I
feel like if I personally haven't heard
people like reference New York as
Gotham's having a father like little
nicknames I've heard four for New York
like Big Apple obviously yeah yeah
personally I haven't heard much in terms
of it being references Gotham but I also
assumed that it was so right so yeah
maybe there's some shoes I don't know
what they would what they call SF I
always just hear people call it the City
or San Fran or sand for that place with
all the poop oh my gosh that's so true
yeah but I I like doesn't have any
nicknames like it doesn't have the Big
Apple or anything like that okay I think
I think we did it I think we did so
let's just go to the top of this
building then we can wrap up because I
think yeah well we'll get one way what
are they shooting you yeah there we go
nice one final view of the city smoking
in on fire but yeah well that wraps it
up for our stream today we were just
checking out a tiny little bit of DC
Universe Online it's now available on
the switch it just came out on the
switch yesterday so yeah if you guys are
interested go ahead and give it a
download because it's free and it's
which you have nothing to lose except
time exactly and from the Nifty FAQ
section I was reading online you don't
need the Nintendo online subscription
either you could just go on and play so
check it out if you want it does it is a
hefty file size but you know definitely
worth a shot if you are on the fence
about it
and yeah tune in tomorrow we will be
back with more games more action and
just have a good one in general peace
out y'all bye everybody thanks for
stopping by